Well, what a morning already church.
Really what a last couple weeks it's been.
Uh, it's just amazing
to watch lives transformed from places all over the world.
And, uh, we get a chance to participate in that.
I mean, one of our church's values is life giving hope,
where we are, uh, reflecting the gospel
of Jesus with delight.
Uh, as we build relationships infused with grace
and joy, uh, we're seeing that happen.
Like, uh, it's a palpable sense of excitement
that is really sweet to be a part of.
So, super grateful to be here.
Uh, let's turn now to God's word, back
to our he Shall Reign series in one Samuel,
one Samuel Chapter 25 is where we're gonna be today.
Now, last week we saw the future King David.
He was continuing his growth process.
He's learning how to trust God for justice on his behalf.
Uh, the current king Saul was chasing him down, trying
to hunt his life.
And, and so David had to entrust Saul even to God,
and that was a growth process.
Well, today we're gonna see continued growth in David.
He actually, here we'll face a different kind
of unexpected opportunity.
We'll see how David grows in trust through that.
But it's also gonna lead us to some things.
It's gonna lead us to examine how we face
unexpected temptations in our own lives even today.
So I wanna start by just reading the
first part of verse one.
It almost offhandedly mentions a really important part
of the narrative here.
So look at just first, first part of verse one.
Now, Samuel died like, that's it.
I just, this great man
that the whole thing's named after, right?
Just Samuel died and all Israel assembled
and mourned for him and they buried him in his
house at Rama.
If you remember Samuel, of course,
yes, it's named after him.
But he was God's prophet during this season.
And he was the one who anointed both Saul
and David as the future kings.
Saul first and then David, when Saul lost it,
that was even God's vessel for Saul was to bring
that judgment on him to say,
you don't get to be the king anymore.
Uh, here's how this is gonna work out.
And so Samuel is a really important piece
of the puzzle through the process.
But what happened when he died was that it removed a measure
of protection for David
because David could have said if anybody questioned his
credentials, he could have, Hey, go ask Samuel.
I mean, Samuel anointed me, so he's now Samuel's gone.
And so how would Saul
and even others respond to David?
Now that Samuel's dead,
it's gonna show up a lot in later chapters, especially, but,
but here we'll see just hints of it, how important it is.
And so look at the rest of verse one down through verse 13.
This is the rest of the scene involving David.
Then David Rose and went down to the wilderness of Piran.
And there was a man in Mayon whose business was in Carmel.
The man was very rich. He had 3000 sheep, a thousand goats.
He was shearing his sheep in Carmel.
Now the name of the man was Neal, the name
of his wife Abigail.
The woman was discerning and beautiful,
but the man was harsh and badly behaved.
It was Caite. David heard in the wilderness
that Neal was shearing his sheep.
And so David sent 10 young men
and David said to young men, go to Carmel.
Go to Neal. Greet him in my name. Thus you shall greet him.
Peace be to you, Nial. Peace be to your house.
Peace be to all that you have.
I hear that you have shearers now
your shepherds have been with us.
We did them no harm. They miss nothing
all the time they're in Carmel.
Ask your young men, they'll tell you,
therefore, let my young men find favor in your eyes.
We come on a feast day.
Please give whatever you have at hand
to your servants and to your son.
David. When David's young men came, they said all this
to the ball in the name of David.
And then they waited and Nal
answered David's servants, who's David?
Who is the son of Jesse? There are many servants these days
who are breaking away from their masters.
Shall I take my bread and my water
and my meat that I've killed from my shearers
and give it to men who come from I don't know where.
And so David's young men turned away, came back,
told David all this,
and David said to his men, every man strapped on his sword,
every man of them strapped on his sword.
David also strapped on his sword and about 400 men went up
after David while 200 remained with the baggage.
Now we'll come back to that last bit in a second,
but lemme just give you why I structured this sermon the
way I did today.
Really, we're gonna follow the character development
of each person involved here.
So what the text does, it kind of develops them over time.
We see Nal and David already here.
We'll see others as the narrative leads us to those.
But we're gonna just take it
by persons as we go through this.
And you'll see what I mean here.
The first character, of course, we come to is nal.
Now, the character development it gives us is
that his folly, his foolishness led him
to be blind in spirit.
His foolishness led him to be blind in his spirit.
Now, if you didn't catch it while we're reading through
that, the first thing we learned about this man
was not his name, but that he was very rich.
Like he had a booming sheep business.
Everything was going well for him.
The problem comes when his name is actually introduced
because his name nal, in the original language,
actually means fool.
Now you wouldn't name your kid fool, right?
Like, like you introduced to my son conman, right?
Like, you wouldn't do that. This, this is my daughter joker.
No, you wouldn't do those kinds of things.
But in the, in the Old Testament, they seemed to name
and we don't know why, but it's,
it's almost prophetic when you look at a person's name.
We don't know why the parents would've thought they did
what they did, but Neal's name
sets the tone for this whole chapter.
Now, just as a minor point,
it doesn't really have a whole lot to do with this chapter,
but, but the, the enemy of David so far has been Saul.
Saul never appears in this chapter.
He'll show up in 26 again.
He was in 24, but he is not here in 25.
So what we learn here is that in a sense you could see Nial
as like a stand in for Saul, kind of the foil
that David is interacting with almost as a trial run,
a practice run in how to deal with Saul.
He did it right in 24. He'll do it again in 26.
But, but here it's like there's a practice session.
The Lord gives him not a one-to-one correlation,
but you can see what, why, what I mean when we get to it.
'cause watch again what happened here in chapter 25,
David's men had been good to Neal's men.
Like they protected him. They provided for him.
They had not taken anything from them.
And so David's good to Neal.
He assumed Nial was gonna be good to him back. Right?
Yet, what did he get? Look at verses 10 and 11 again.
Who is David? Who is the son of Jesse?
There are many servants breaking away from their masters.
Shall I take my bread and water
and meat and give it to these guys?
I don't even know where they're come from.
Like should I do that?
Like David got dismissed, he got shunned.
He almost even got accused of rebelling against his master.
So clearly Nabal was foolish in his
interpretation of Israel's political situation.
He didn't understand how this thing was working out.
Possibly, we don't know this for sure, but possibly
'cause Saul might have even been enabling prosperity
for Neal somehow, Which
that happens a lot politically, right?
You give me a favor, I'll give you a favor
and that could have been happening here.
But all we know is
that Nal was foolish according to his name.
And even his actions, he was self-sufficient.
He was prideful and that made him blind spiritual.
He couldn't discern what God was doing through David.
He couldn't see it that maybe God had something other than
store than Saul
and he couldn't even see that God was the one who had
provided all that Neal had to begin with.
It wasn't 'cause he was a master businessman.
It was 'cause God had given him all that
and he just never saw it.
But here's what Neal's response did.
It provided a massive temptation for David.
David has grown a lot
in the chapters we've walked to until this point,
but here we continue
to see it even maybe an exponential way.
We see his growth in obedience.
David's continuing to grow all the way
through God's shaping him into the man he
needs him to be, to be the king.
But here we see it in full color,
his growth in obedience to God.
And I love how honest the Bible is
because did you see how David responded initially
to Nepal's refusal?
Everybody get up. Get your sword. Let's go.
And we know what he's intending, right?
In fact, later it records it.
Verses 21 and 22, show his intentions says,
surely in vain, David says, surely in vain
of I guarded all this fellow has in the wilderness so
that nothing's missed and all that belonged to him,
he's returned to me evil for good God do so to the enemies
of David and more Also, if by morning I leave so much
as one male of all who belonged to Nal,
that was David's intention.
Meaning he was, he was going with these 400 men
to go kill every male in the ball's clan.
Dozens of them probably. That was in David's heart.
But did you catch what just happened here?
It was another unexpected opportunity for David.
Remember last week, he's hiding in the cave.
Saul, his enemy who's trying to kill him comes in the cave
and David has the opportunity
to slay his enemy, but he doesn't.
Nal presents David with another unexpected opportunity.
How's he gonna respond?
Would he pass the test like he did last time?
Well, initially it sure seemed like he wouldn't
because he is on a mission.
He's heated. He's going to kill all of these men.
Watch what happens next.
Starting in verse 14, we see another character not
introduced, but developed
because we saw her already in verse three,
a woman who's discerning and beautiful.
It says, watch starting in verse 14, what happens here?
But one of the young men told Abigail the ball's wife
to behold, David sent messengers outta the wilderness
to greet our master and he railed at them.
Yet David's men were very good to us
and we suffered no harm.
We didn't miss anything when we were in the fields.
As long as we went with them, they were a wall
to us both day and night.
All the while we are with them keeping the sheep.
Now therefore, know this and consider what you should do
for harm is determined against our master nal
and against all his house.
He's such a worthless man that no one can speak to him.
When, uh, Abigail then made haste, made 200 loaves
and two skins of wine, 500
or five sheep already prepared five seas of parched grain,
a hundred clusters of raisins, 200 cakes of figs,
laid 'em on donkeys.
And she said to her, young men, go before me.
Behold, I'll come after you.
But she did not tell her husband to ball
as she wrote on the donkey came
down under the cover of the mountain.
Behold David and his men came down toward
her and she met them.
Now, this is beginning
to develop this character named
Abigail Neal's wife, right?
And right away we start to see what verse three said,
discerning and beautiful.
We start to see this discernment
show up right away, don't we?
In fact, her wisdom throughout this passage,
her wisdom will show up as grace in action
to all kinds of people involved here.
Abigail's wisdom and discernment will show up as grace
in action to nal to David to others
involved in this as well.
'cause did you see her act here? What, what did she do?
She on her own had the idea to try to pacify
David's anger like she knew Nal was a
fool like everybody else did.
She knew I I need to spare his life somehow.
This is a way to do it. Here's my idea.
And she goes about it in a wise way.
She knew she had to avert some imminent crisis.
And so how did she do it?
Just like anybody else would do it.
She sent a charcuterie board,
Right? Do you see that?
You read through this thing, you're like,
what I, I had one of those at Thanksgiving, like
that was just, oh, is food, meat, bread,
snacks, all kinds of stuff.
She sent it ahead to say to David, who's got a hungry army
by the way, she's like here.
It was a peace offering. You might say, did it work though?
Like was her spiritual discernment enough
to avert the crisis that was coming for Neal?
Starting in verse 23, watch this.
When Abigail saw David, she hurried
and got down from the donkey and fell
before David on her face and bowed to the ground.
She fell at his feet
and said on me alone, my Lord, be the guilt.
Please let your servant speak in your ears.
Let hear the words of your servant.
Let not my Lord regard this worthless fellow nal for
as his name is.
So is he. Nal is his name. Folly is with him.
But I your servant did not see the young men
of my Lord whom you sent.
Now then my Lord, as the Lord, Yahweh lives
as your soul lives
because the Lord has restrained you from blood guilt
and from saving with your own hand.
Now then let your enemies
and those who seek to do evil to my Lord be asal.
And now let this present all the food
that your servants brought to my Lord be given
to the young men who follow my Lord.
Please forgive the trespass of your servant.
For the Lord will certainly make my Lord David a sure house
because he's fighting the battles of the Lord.
Evil shall not be found in you as long as you live.
If men rise up to pursue you, seek your life.
The life of my Lord shall be bound in the bundle
of the living in the care of the Lord your God,
the lives your enemies, he shall sling out
as from the hall of a sling.
And when the Lord Yahweh has done to my Lord, according
to all the good that he's spoken concerning you
and has appointed you prince
or king over Israel, my Lord shall have no cause of grief
or pangs of conscience for having shed blood without cause
or for my Lord working salvation himself.
And when the Lord's dealt well with you,
remember your servant like is
that not an incredible speech?
She comes with such humility.
She comes with such just grace
dripping out of everything.
Like she comes with this courage to meet this man,
man she's never met before, who could take her life,
who's coming to take her husband and all her family's life.
She comes with such theological understanding
of the whole situation, doesn't she?
She knew exactly David's anointed role.
She'd heard about Samuel anointed.
She knew what David was called to do.
She knew how that would play out.
She also knew how that should play out.
She remembered Samuel talking about
the way the king should be.
She knew God's character
and so she knew David, you should never try
to work salvation your own hands,
never try to work it out yourself.
It's not an amazing picture of grace through Abigail
to David, like her wisdom on how
to handle this situation.
Again, grace in action to spare nial from being killed,
to spare David from following some track.
He didn't ne follow to spare all kinds of people.
This is grace in action. How she do it. She told the truth.
She reminded David of his calling.
She refocused his mind back towards the Lord
And she humbled herself even to the point
where she took blame, where she had no blame.
Remember that she wasn't involved. These men came to Nal.
He was the one who spouted off. She was completely.
And she had no idea this even happened.
And yet she took the blame and watch how David responded.
Look at verse 32. And David
said to Abigail, blessed be the Lord.
Yahweh, the God of Israel who sent you this day to meet me.
Blessed be your discretion, your discernment.
And blessed be you who've kept me this day from blood guilt
and from working salvation with my own hand, for surely
as the Lord, the God of Israel lives who's restrained me
from hurting you unless you'd hurried
and come to meet me truly
by mourning there had not been left to the ball so much
as one male, meaning I was gonna do
this until you showed up.
And then David received from her
hand what she had brought him.
And he said to her, go up in peace to your house.
See, I've obeyed your voice. I've granted your petition.
Abigail's plan worked right? See that it worked.
And David, what we learned about him here is he continued
growing in his obedience to the Lord.
He was reminded that he was not supposed
to take matters into his own hands.
He was supposed to trust the Lord to work it out himself.
And he knew he needed that. God knew he needed that himself.
He needed to grow and
and watch how this has worked out.
24, chapter 24, he had a test.
I gotta trust God with Saul.
I mean, he's right in front of me.
I could take his life, but no God, I'm not supposed to touch
or anointed here, okay?
God, I'm not supposed to take out Nal who offended me.
I'm not supposed to do that.
I gotta trust you to work it out.
And we'll see the full development of
that next week in chapter 26 again with Saul
that David grew into this
Understanding And
what a blessing Abigail was to David, right?
She intervened, she reminded David of his calling,
who he was in the Lord.
She helped David overcome the temptation of vengeance.
And as a result, David matured.
Just reading this, I was reminded
of Hebrews chapter three, verse 13.
It says, exhort one another every day as long
as it's called today, that none of you may be hardened
by the deceitfulness of
Sin.
And David was deceived here by sin, wasn't it?
And we all need that. We all need people who willing
to step into the gap that we, we get off track
and we think we're doing right, but but no, we're not.
And and God intervenes through someone.
We all need people like that.
We need parents who are going to help us
stay away from foolishness as we grow and mature
before we can make our own decisions.
We need godly friends
who will courageously call us out when we're about
to walk down a path that will really hurt us and others.
We need pastors who are willing to tell us the truth
whenever we're wandering away from God's plan.
We need church members to support us
as we choose holiness over the ways of the world.
Like we need people who will look at us and say truth to us.
Every one of us needs that. And that's what happened here.
And Abigail is held up in such high esteem as a result.
In fact, I love how one preacher back in the 18
hundreds described it.
He says, Abigail is the conquerors,
one woman in the right mightier than 400 men in the wrong.
A hurricane stopped at the site of a water Lily
Niagara dashed back by a drop of dew
by her bravery intact.
Abigail has saved her husband, saved her home, and put
before all ages an illustrious specimen of
what a woman can do if she's godly and prudent
and self-sacrificing and vigilant
and devoted to the interests of others.
May we all be like Abigail.
And so far so good in the story then, right?
Yet here's the unanswered question so far.
Listen, the ball gonna get away with this.
He clearly was opposed to God by being opposed to David.
And the way he handled David was completely ungodly.
So was Neal gonna get away with this?
I mean, David was gonna go take care of it.
No, I gotta trust you. God.
Was Neal going to get away with it?
David's like, man, I trust you with Saul.
Can I trust you with Neal? Well watch what God did.
He used Abigail again in a way, starting in verse 36,
Abigail came to Neal.
Behold he was holding a feast in his house
like the feast of a king.
That's just pride, right?
A lot of money thought he was king,
and Neal's heart was married within him.
He was very drunk. And
so she told him nothing at all till the morning light in the
morning when the wine had gone out of Nal.
His wife told him these things
and his heart died within him.
And he became as a stone.
And about 10 days later,
the Lord struck Neal and he died.
See that God worked it out.
David didn't even have to lift a finger.
In fact, that's what David says next in verse 39,
when David heard that Neal was dead, he said,
blessed be the Lord who has veed.
The insult I received at the hand of Nal
and has kept back his servant, meaning David,
God kept me back from wrongdoing.
The Lord has returned the evil of Nal on his own head.
David's like, God did this. God delivered me.
See it. It might be a little hard to understand
or difficult to see in this passage,
but the point that's being made is that God is sovereign
and he has a purpose in redemption.
He has a purpose in working out the
deliverance of his people.
He will always accomplish his plan.
Now here's the thing on our side of that, the timing
might not always work out like we think it should.
Even the mechanism God uses the application of
that may not be what we would selfishly want.
Like it would've felt really good for David
to walk into Neal's camp and just slaughter them.
It would've been the absolute wrong thing to do,
but that's what David would've preferred.
But what we have to do is trust God's promise
that he's working it out and he will.
'cause remember for David, the Lord had promised David
that he was going to be the king
and he was going to eventually put all
of David's enemies down before him.
And so David has this opportunity to do it to Saul,
to do it in Nal.
Next week, we'll see him again with Saul.
David had the opportunities and he had to trust God's timing
and God's ways there.
This scene is a reminder of that for David.
Abigail completely understood that for David in many ways
she's like, you know David, you're gonna be the king.
We know that. And David, all your
enemies are gonna be down before you.
That's fine. But you can't take justice in your own hands.
You've gotta remember that, David, you can't do that.
You cannot work out salvation in your own hands.
And what did David do whenever he heard of Neal's death?
He was reminded again that that's what God does.
And just think of the encouragement it would've given him
knowing that Saul was still out there
somewhere coming after him.
God said, you can trust me. He did within the ball.
God took care of the ball. And so, you know,
know David's like, all right God, I'll trust you with Saul
and we'll see the full development of
that next week in chapter 26.
But really, that's the whole point.
We've said over
and over the last couple weeks, you see it here,
when we trust God to do his work, when we don't take
matters into our own hands, we trust him.
He will work it out.
Maybe not our time, maybe not our ways, but he will.
I mean, just think about how David wrote this again.
David was running away from Psalm,
he's writing Psalms all in the caves.
He's hiding in. But this is
what he says in Psalm 57, Be merciful
Oh God, be merciful to me.
For in you, my soul takes refuge
in the shadow of your wings.
I will take refuge till the storms of destruction pass
By.
I cry out to God most high to God who fulfills his purpose
for me in the cave running away
from someone trying to kill him.
He's like, God, God, I'm, I'm under your wings.
I'm, I'm hiding in you.
I trust you're gonna fulfill your purpose for me.
Sure it doesn't look like it right now, but I trust you.
Can we, can we trust the Lord in our
time of need till the storms of destruction pass by?
Can we trust our lives to him who judges justly
that he will work out what he wants to happen in his time?
And here's what can we trust him with that?
Can we, David did, can we?
Because he's got a purpose. God has a purpose in redemption.
If we are his by faith in Jesus Christ,
we know he has a purpose.
And at the very least part of his purpose is
that he's gonna take us home with him someday.
And that simple truth, as much
as things don't work out the way we want him to hear
that simple truth, he's taken us home someday
that can give us extreme ability to stand strong even today,
To stand in hope in the face of whatever comes your way,
no matter what it is, God can give you hope.
Knowing that is coming
even, even in the face of the temptations
that like the waves on the beach.
Just keep pounding your life.
You can stand strong in hope even when
those temptations
Pound you.
See, here's the thing about this passage, the surface
of it, we kind of get it.
We kind of understand it. But there's something going on
much deeper below the surface here.
Really this is a battle between the kingdom of God
and the kingdom of Satan.
Because the enemy of our souls brought this
surprise attack on David.
He knew who David was.
He knew what David was supposed to be.
And David's walking around the wilderness for years.
Potentially. He knows Saul's a guy he's gotta worry about.
And so he's always looking around for Saul.
He's like, man, I gotta, where's Saul? Let's find out.
Let's go the opposite way. Let's go around the mountain.
Like he's looking for Saul. He knows that Saul is a threat.
And then this Nal guy comes outta nowhere. Wait a second.
I wasn't, look, hold up. I thought Saul was my problem.
And now Na ball shows up. What was God doing?
He was continuing to allow David to be tested,
to grow his faith,
to get attacked from a different direction, yet still have
to trust God in the middle of it.
Now, I love again how honest the Bible is.
'cause David initially was gonna
take things into his own hands.
He was not handling this right from the beginning.
But God graciously intervened through Abigail.
And that is what led David to trust God in a new way.
'cause remember the beginning said that Samuel had died.
That adds a layer to this that says, you know what?
Hey David, are you still gonna trust
and obey even if Samuel's not around?
Like you could go to Samuel and listen and,
and think through and process how to handle this situation,
but Samuel's not there anymore.
Are you gonna handle it the same way God is continuing
to layer tests on David's heart.
James one says, know this, my beloved brothers,
let every person be quick to hear, slow to speak, slow
to anger for the anger
of man does not produce the righteousness of God.
David, would you pass that test
even without Samuel there to help you?
And listen, this this matters not just for David's life
or for the sparing of people in the family.
This, this matters for David's life.
Yes, but it also matters
because the Messiah would eventually come
from the line of David.
And the question being asked here is, what kind
of throne would that Messiah come to sit on?
Would it be a throne of
I'm taking justice into my own hands,
I'm handling it myself.
I'm gonna bring it about myself.
Is that the kind of throne that the savior would come to?
Or would it be a throne full of humility and sacrifice
and trusting the Lord fully?
So you see how this test matters for David,
but it matters much more than that as well.
Well, listen, church, we're we're not in the line of David.
We're not in the line of the Messiah.
We don't have to be held to that idea, but,
but the same attacks that David was facing,
we face every day as well.
See second Corinthians two says that Satan is scheming
against God's people trying
to derail their lives away from God's plan and purpose.
Is that not what he was doing with David?
He's trying to scheme this way to get somebody else there.
First Peter five, eight says,
Satan is a roaring lion looking for someone to devour.
Was that not what he was doing with David?
He wanted to destroy David through this way.
Is that not what he does with us?
And listen, there's one thing we know about the enemy.
He does not work most often through these
full on from the front kind
of assaults that you can see coming.
Because then what we could do is we could prepare.
We, we know it's coming. We can see the army this way.
We can see the battle we can set up,
we can prepare, we can know it's coming.
That's not often how he works.
He often brings his attacks in very surprising ways
When we're not prepared for it.
Whenever we're at our weakest or when things are unexpected.
You've seen national Geographic, right?
That gazelle goes off to drink, completely oblivious
to the lions creeping through the grass,
hunting it right next to it.
It thinks it's safe, it has no expectations,
and all of a sudden it gets taken.
And so the enemy was coming after, sit after David.
If the enemy's coming after us, then we better be prepared
and know how to stand.
Right? So how do we do that?
How can we overcome temptation?
There's only one way through the hope of Christ
who offers us victory.
Don't walk away from here saying, well,
I gotta try harder to overcome temptation.
The only hope you have
and I have is to rest in the victory
of Christ.
Listen Christ who, who not only defeated sin
and temptation by living a perfect life,
resurrecting from the grave, but
who also offers us victory when we face temptation.
Now, he might actually send a physical person
to be the intervention just like Abigail was for Dave.
He might do that. He's done it in my life.
He's probably done it in most of our lives. He might.
But listen, he providentially promises
to intervene in one specific way.
As one Corinthians 10 13 says,
no temptation has overtaken you.
That is not common to man. Meaning we all face them.
God is faithful
and he will not let you be tempted beyond your ability.
But with the temptation, he will also provide the way
of escape that you may be able to endure it.
I know what it feels like
that you feel like there's no way I can't do
what this temptation is asking me to do.
It can feel like there's no way out.
It can feel like you just have to sin.
But if you are in Christ, listen,
if you get nothing else today, if you are in Christ
by faith, if you are his, you don't have give in.
You don't have to like, even if that's just your phrase.
Like, I don't have to do that. I don't have to.
Now, why can you say that with such confidence?
Because If you're in Christ, you are a new
creation in Christ.
And Galatians two 20 says,
I have been crucified with Christ.
I no longer live, but Christ lives in me.
So how can you say I, I don't have to do that.
I don't have to take vengeance.
David would've said, I don't have to do that. Why?
Because you have a savior
who lives his life through you.
That means you don't have to fight it on your own.
You don't have to fight it yourself.
You can just let him fight.
I I no longer live Christ lives in me.
Jesus, you gotta do this right?
Isn't that good news?
Because listen, I know I'm not
strong enough to fight temptation.
I know how weak I, how I give in
so quickly when I'm trusting myself, man, it's,
it's almost instantaneous.
I need someone who's overcome it for me.
I need a victor to stand in my place
and fight the battle for me.
That's what I need. And praise God
that he has provided that
For me, And he's provided that for you.
If we rest in the victory
and the power of Jesus, the overcomer.